the other one that I wanted to bring
back here is good girls revolt because I
know that one didn't come to the to a
close in the best possible way but now
that we've kind of been removed from it
for a certain period of time is there
anything that looking back you could
think of that cancellation and then I
don't know put a positive spin on
something that you learned from that
experience and how it all went down that
you could then try to apply to new shows
that you're working on um oh my god it
was such a pivotal a pivotal time it was
right for the election it was right for
all of the me to movement and it felt
like such a good time to be making a
show like that you know where women were
coming together and we and we were
focusing on sexual harassment and
getting you know equal opportunities and
it was just such an inspiring time to go
to set to work on something like that
and then it all went down in this really
frustrating way to be honest but is the
if the one thing that I have gotten
positive from that is that I still get
asked about it from women everywhere and
men too I think like I when restaurants
were a thing you know the last waitress
that I had would be like I really loved
you in good girls revolt that show will
always stick with me if that inspired
people still to this day and inspires
women still to stand up for themselves
and to keep fighting the good fight I
think that that's the hope and the
beauty that came from that show and it's
kind of a timeless project to be honest
I feel like you can always go back and
you can always watch that show and get
something from it and if it inspires you
to keep fighting I think that that's a
good thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]